okay welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speakers let's go over some rules and
Logistics the same rules and Logistics I
have been
announcing every time how we host the
speaker in ddks seminar all right first
of all please mute yourself during the
talk unless you have questions if you
have questions you are welcome to mute
and ask
um otherwise please use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q a session at the end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel that's about it now let
me introduce our speaker today it is an
honor to host the story in mitron who is
a professor at the Department of
Mathematics in University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill he received his PhD
from Polytech polytanica University
Bucharest Romania in 1995 before he
joined UNC in 2002 he was a research
associate at the University of
Washington Seattle from 1999 to 2002 and
the guest scientist in Germany from 1998
to 1999. your third and quartered nine
books and chapters and more than 40
referred Journal papers today sorry will
talk about data-driven information
geometry approach to stochastic model
reduction which is a very interesting
topic obviously so please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk now without
further Ado let me touch the button to
zorin by asking one random question as
usual today's random question is what is
your idea of the perfect day for example
you got the Nobel Prize
no the perfect day is a fair wind and me
and my sailing thingy Out on the Ocean
oh that sounds wonderful all right the
stage is yours sorry
okay
um hello I can't see anybody so I can't
be quite that Interactive
but please do interrupt with any
questions if I understood correctly the
general atmosphere of this series of
talks it's more in the way of working
seminars about
ideas to approach these kinds of
interesting data Rich problems and
that's the way that I group these slides
so rather than focus on polished
published results I want to kind of open
up my workshop here to everybody to see
if there's points of interest that we
can collaborate on or things that might
raise your interest
that being said let me give you an
overview
we're going to be looking at first a bit
of motivation on why I was led after
looking at a bunch of problems that
involve
stochastic microscopic physics
at the particular approach
embedded in
classical differential geometry but with
a Twist namely
looking at the differential geometry of
manifolds whose points are probability
distribution functions
this is something which was pioneered in
mathematics by the work of a Japanese
mathematician mostly Kamari
and there was a great focus on
analytical descriptions of such
manifolds
my interest
based upon the physical motivation I'll
be going into in just a bit
is in extending the analytical framework
to a computational one that can be used
in various types of applications and
I've picked two applications today that
we can go into
one relatively straightforward
application one more involved thing from
biomechanics
motivation
we all went through school and learned
classical physics that's the way the
world works one of the interesting
questions is why does it work why is
classical physics so successful and of
course we have a pretty good idea that
it all boils down to that one single
fact of
physical knowledge that Feynman told us
we should hang on to If ever we come out
of a nuclear cataclysm namely the atomic
hypothesis matter is composed of very
small
portions atoms that interact with one
another
and the fact that they are so many in
number
allow us mathematically to apply the law
of large numbers
and the central limit theorem
the way that I like to think about this
is that the law of large numbers tells
us that even though we might have
stochastic motion at some microscopic
scale we can Define averages therefore
we can think that nature is rational we
can make predictions on the average
behavior of something to be expected we
can measure things
the central limit theorem then tells us
that if we have lots and lots of such
systems that we measure
not only can we find averages but we can
furthermore
describe in a very quantitative manner
of the deviations from the hose averages
and basically we have our familiar
expression of going to a normal
distribution of the deviations in
measurement and something that converges
with the inverse square root of the
number of
trials that we carry out so in this way
nature is kind we can do analytical
averaging
in the sense that if we introduce a
Hermit block polynomial scalar product
and we have any probability distribution
that comes about from microscopic
physics we can carry out those averages
analytically and come up with
macroscopic laws that we use all the
time
this is a perhaps most famously
exemplified of course by gas kinetics if
you have n particles let's say it's an
ideal
uh hard sphere particles just
interacting by collisions and you're
interested in characterizing this gas
you can imagine that it each particle
can occupy a certain energy level at a
certain probability
and keeping things
discreet for a moment to ease the
derivation
you have a bunch of constraints actually
not that many just two one
standard normalization of a probability
distribution all the probabilities have
to add up to one they're all positive
also
and a total energy
and the way that we can then come up
with the Maxwell was one distribution is
something which is familiar from just
classical statistical physics we
construct the H function or the entropy
and then invoke this hypothesis of
molecular chaos
to maximize the entropy and thereby come
up with a maximum bullsman distribution
since this is something of gaussian form
nature is kind it allows us to integrate
this and plug it in to things such as
the boltzmann equation from kinetic
physics on the bottom there
and then come up with ways that we can
derive
our equations for macroscopic fluid flow
the Euler equations in the first
approximation not your Stokes in the
second Bernard and third and so on
so that's the overview of classical
physics
now
if we were to do a critique of this
you come across the following
observations that sure if I'm observing
things like uh
ideal gas at my
scale mainly let's say something
10 centimeters length scale one second
time scale
I'm observing the behavior of about oh
10 to the 22 particles
they're moving somewhere around the 500
meters per second let's say a thousand
and there are in one second
to the 32 collisions
even though we're kind of used to Monte
Carlo simulations converging slowly as
the inverse square root if you're at 10
to the 32 realizations of your
experiment even that slow convergence
gives you something like 16 digits of
accuracy so not only the law of large
numbers and the central limit theorem
are applicable but they're very accurate
we get essentially something which looks
like deterministic behavior and a
deviation from the deterministic
behavior is something at the level of
our capability of measurement
now when does this break down well we
know it's very sad it breaks down if we
look at the phenomena at much smaller
scales we know that if we keep on
decreasing the scale we keep on seeing
things that appear stochastic but they
are no longer quite satisfying the same
laws we're used to if you're doing mems
microelectronic mechanical systems you
know that you for instance don't have a
no subcondition anymore and that's a
reflection of looking at this
particularly small scale
or you can look at phenomena that are
larger but it just happened to go slower
such that on the time scale of Interest
things evolve slowly
what we obtain in this case falls under
the general umbrella of non-equilibrated
mesoscale physics
and it covers quite a bit of ground
which is of Interest both from the
intellectual theoretical point of view
but also from the Practical point of
view
we typically find ourselves in the
situation that the law of large numbers
is applicable and we can
ascertain average Behavior we can
ascertain what the means of the behavior
should be we should somehow be able to
do a rational prediction
but the central limit theorem itself is
not going to be that useful because
though we know that in Romans of large
realizations we're going to go to a
gaussian deviation from whatever we
expect between measurements and um the
mean for whatever quantity
the
process is now going to be something
which isn't quite at that limit yet
we're going to have we're going to have
probably distribution functions which
are not necessarily going to be gaussian
such examples are just to pick a couple
exemplified in the pictures that we have
here
one for polymer flow
we have a dilute polymer solution
and the interaction of the let's say
Newtonian
background fluid
which transfers energy to polymers
through these microscopic configuration
you can think of as a bunch of balls and
Springs
this interaction to and fro leads to
different behavior and we get what are
known as the viscoelastic
equation to fluid flow
governed by things other than obvious
dose equations things like the old Droid
models
or another example is that of cellular
motility
a cell typically moves by completely
reconfiguring its entire skeleton to go
to a new place the skeleton itself is
composed of actin filaments that grow
cross-link attach in various other ways
into the cellular membrane
and as seen in the phosphorescent
lighting of a particular
up to three protein that governs this
process on the picture on the left of
cellular motility
that reconfiguration is what leads to
the motion of a particular cell
in both of these situations what we have
is something in which we can't describe
the microscopic physics the polymer
configuration when it moves through a
sharp interaction in one case
or the cellular configuration of an
actin Network in the other by any
known apriori probability distribution
yes if I had a very long observation
time in very many experiments perhaps
you let these things relax they would
somehow tend to some normal distribution
but on the scale of interest that we are
looking at the phenomena the probability
distribution describing polymer
configurations or active and network
configurations are not gaussian so
of course if you further decrease your
observation scale you move into
deterministic physics but that's not our
interest our interest is going to be in
this mesoscale regime
so what are the current approaches what
we know a bunch of these a bunch of them
are talked a bunch of them are objects
of current research but in the classical
uh realm of what's being taught in a
typical physics kinetics course you have
things like the Chapman landscow
expansion which you just do a probation
expansion of your probability
distribution and you apply methods of
Applied Mathematics and get something
which gives you a non-gaussian
distribution to some degree of accuracy
within the expansion and the nuts number
or you can find a more
active research front say that you're
looking at a phenomenon you add a
stochastic component but you apply the
traditional method of linear space
methods such as oh you enrich your
finite element basis for the
deterministic part with a stochastic
component that is the next term methods
or you have
a linear space description of the
stochasticity by setting polynomial
chaos expansions in terms of similar
combinations of polynomials that
taken to a classic acidity
or you can also do things like Basin
updates which is very popular in uq
studies
now
the idea behind what I'm going to be
presenting today is to look at a
slightly different approach to the
problem
we are still going to be in the
situation that we're going to think yes
the phenomena this meso scale of physics
admit a description through
probably density function so we're going
to say that we're not in the
deterministic regime we still are going
to have some stochasticity but we're not
at the level of so many interactions
in the volume and time interval of
interest that we are definitely going to
have normal gaussian distributions
the probability distribution is going to
be assumed to be somehow describable
in a parametric form
but we're not going to impose
the particular parametric form of priori
we're not even going to know
how many parameters enter into the
parametric form
we are also going to be interested in
the possibility
that the parameters that arise in the
PDF are going to evolve perhaps in time
perhaps with some parameter governing
the forcing of the system for instance
such as a Reynolds number within the
flow that you accelerate
and the
hypothesis that we've put forward is
then going to be put into a particular
conceptual framework and the conceptual
framework as announced by the title is
that of information Theory
of Shadow information Theory uh perhaps
familiar to most everybody but just A
Brief Review just
talks about
the reliability of receiving messages
over a noisy Channel
so we can think of this message as being
something that we measure from physics
and it contains information about the
microstate of the
particular physical system we're
interested in we have a space of such
possible measurements in physical
language messages of the language of
Shannon Shannon and each one has a
particular probability
associated with the probability we have
an information content or the
self-information this is the negative
log of the probability of a particular
message or a particular measurement
reflecting the fact that
measurements that you do not expect
those that have low probability contain
large information the surprise factor is
the information in this context
in this like
the average information is of course
just a sum over the information of each
message and the probability
within the constraint of normalization
of your probability distribution and it
can be interpreted on as the uncertainty
that you have about the microstate the
system is in
or
equivalently the asserted uncertainty in
what your next measurement about the
system is going to be
if you kind of uh make these things just
a bit more concrete you can set an upper
and lower bound on the average
information
if you have
the
maximization of that particular
functional with respect to all of the
possible probabilities you come across
that the maximum is obtained under the
constraint of normalization and nothing
else
by the equity probable distribution the
probability is essentially one over the
size of the system and the maximum
maximum average information
which we'll see as the entropy is going
to be the log of the number of states
and this is things that we are familiar
with from statistical physics
the minimum is when you have
a certain microstate namely there is one
microstate which has probably one and
all the other ones have probability zero
and that's the range of our average
information about the system
so this is going to be the approach
and in
presenting how to work this approach
into something workable in the types of
applications that I mentioned
we're going to go through a bit of
presentation synopsis of information
Theory and then more importantly
information geometry
information theory is essentially as I
mentioned the study of
functionals that we can associate with
random events the information
self-information itself
is a
transformation of a probability and then
if we think about all the probabilities
we can form various functionals such as
the average information which turns out
to be exactly what we understand
physically by entropy or
also if we have a certain knowledge of
the system that is incorporated and you
can break it apart into two parts the
typical things that we are familiar with
and we join entropy conditional entropy
or Mutual information
these things are kind of familiar they
satisfy typical things that we are
also going to encounter in Bayesian
updates of probability distributions
let's now move on though to something
which might be a bit more unfamiliar
this is typically not part of the
general presentation of
differential geometry
though it uses classical differential
geometry methods and namely
the
differential geometry approach
to
families of probability distribution
the objective here is that we would like
to look at not one
particular distribution but we'd like to
look at
many probably distributions that are
parameterized in some way
and we would like to describe the
intrinsic geometry of these sets of
family distributions so you have
at this point
the construction of
a set of probability distributions in
which we have probability distribution
for some random variable achieving the
variable the value X and that
probability distribution is parametrized
by the parameter X PSI these parameters
side there n of them we don't exactly
know what they are
and this is a structure now that we will
make
uh to be
a manifold in the sense that we will
assume that there are multiple possible
parametrizations
and all of them are of classy Infinity
they're smooth and they're diffiomorphic
to one another they're equivalent
this is the third introduction of a
manifold because the manifold points in
this context are probably distributions
it is called a statistical manifold
and a standard example of course would
be just a multivariate normal
distribution like that we have here
in which we have
a multivariate distribution over K
variables and this is described by these
parameters namely K means
and
a covariance matrix which can be given
in full form as a k by K Matrix we also
know of course that it has to be
positive definite and symmetric so we
can make the number of parameters be
half of that essentially
now what is going to be our Viewpoint
it's useful to keep a very Elementary
linear algebra picture in front of us
for in the back of our minds as we go
through
the generalization to statistical
manifolds namely just standardly Square
cylinder spaces
everybody's of course
familiar with this standard presentation
we have a large dimensional Vector maybe
some data you want to express it in a
compact form as a linear combination of
some basis vectors and you project down
onto
the column space or the range of that
particular operator that you want to use
as your expression for the approximation
this corresponds to least squares and
the standard two Norm
but more importantly from our point of
view
it corresponds to a particular way of
thinking of how we obtain that
approximation
it's the minimization of a distance with
respect to all possible
other approximations that would lie in
this linear Subspace
of course the minimization is something
that we understand intuitively as just
being an application of
the Pythagorean theorem and then
minimizing the error making the
hypotenuse of that triangle be
essentially the
single distance
corresponding to the orthogonal
projection from B down onto the column
space of a
we can do this very efficiently which is
why we like it so much we can do
incomplete
QR factorizations come up with a
projector and thereby come up with an
approximation
now
with this in the back of our minds
if we go back
to our multivariad gaussian notice that
our parameters are these PSI that are
the means arising here the covariances
they arise inside of the argument of an
exponential and they also get multiplied
with one another
so if we want to describe
on Bully distribution such as these
gaussians in terms of these parameters
we're going to have to face the problem
that that is no longer a linear
relationship
we're going to have to consider what
happens when we work on now
essentially curve manifolds in which our
standard euclidean geometry has to be
modified
we know that this will typically involve
the definition of a new metric which
will no longer have coefficients drawn
from the identity Matrix there are going
to be coefficients that correspond to
your scalar product on that particular
manifold
we're going to have to then further
think about
euclidean distance in our normal space
is something intuitive but what happens
if we want to define a distance between
probability distribution functions
and then most importantly for
applications how to maintain efficiency
how to be able to do this in a way that
still is something that we can actually
work with in Practical applications
so now I will go through a bit of an
overview of the differential geometry
background
then the approach to constructing
manifolds in Practical cases and then
finally I'll close with a couple of
applications
so before I go into this uh I kind of
laid out the motivation in the
background any questions up to this
point before I move on
yeah any questions
like I said I can't see anybody I just
see my own presentation so I want to
make sure that it's interactive and I
just don't keep on going
yeah yeah I have a question oh great
great so what in the case of the
statistical manifold defined by those uh
n Plus
uh maybe can bring up the previous slide
please yeah the K plus uh K choose uh
two uh this thing parameters what is the
dimension of this manifold
in this particular case we know the
dimension it's going to be K plus
um K times K minus 1 okay plus one over
two it's exactly the number of
independent parameters
okay but the points on the manifold are
are they the the collection of these
parameters or are the probability
distributions defined with respect to
those parameters
I'm on this manifold of Dimension K plus
K squared let's say to make it easier
for me to refer to it and that means
that if I'm at that point I know what mu
and sigma is
therefore I know the probability
distribution
right okay I see so and your notion of a
distance is how to define not a distance
between the parameters themselves but
actually the distributions defined by
those parameters correct that's the
essential aspect okay thank you
okay okay
all right so I'll move on
now what makes euclidian geometry so
easy of course is that on a flat
manifold if you think about the tangent
space to the manifold it's the same at
all points uh this essentially that
mouthful that if I'm in the plane and I
think about the tangent manifold at a
point in the plane it's the plane itself
and it's the same everywhere
that does not happen if I'm on a curve
manifold of course
the picture over there is the schematic
of the situation in which if I'm at a
particular point on the manifold then
the approach of differential geometry is
to say let me look at infinitesimally
close points thereby taking for instance
the derivatives of the
curvilinear coordinates the parameters
of the statistical distribution in our
case
these Define
vectors and the span of these vectors is
a tangent space
which is defined infinitesimally at that
point
but of course the tangent space at one
point if the manifold is curved is no
longer going to be coincident with the
tangent space at another point
so if I would like to do any comparison
between what happens at two different
points I have to be able to
transport a vector from one tangent
space back to a reference tangent space
if we think about our standard
definition of a derivative f of x plus h
minus f of x over H we assume that f of
x plus h lives in the same space as f of
x when we do that particular subtraction
if they would live in different spaces
I'd have to transport it to a common
space and then do it in order to do a
differential
this is something which is formalized by
the notion of a connection we have to
Define how we move
the direction of these vectors from
point to point and because we're going
to be considering very small
displacements this is something which is
a linear mapping between the tangent
spaces at infinitesimally closed points
this is the parallel transport which is
given by the capital P symbol from point
P to point P prime a mapping from the
tangent space at Point P to the tangent
Square set P Prime
if you do a standard expansion of what
the deviation between the tangent Vector
along one coordinate line is in the old
tangent space with respect to the
same tangent Vector to the same
coordinate line the new one you get what
are known as the connection coefficients
and
specifying the connection coefficients
or how you move the tangent vectors of
parameter lines from one point to the
other is a specification of how we work
on a manifold
now
you can have and we'll see in just a bit
multiple connections on the same
manifold depending on how you connect
points
and the idea is that
we can use this to our advantage as
we'll see when we extend our least
squares procedure
finally what we do when we specify
connection coefficients is especially
we're generalizing the notion of a
derivative
again to come back to the elementary
calculus example f of x plus h minus f
of x over H we're assuming that we're
moving at the same rate along the x axis
if we move at some kind of differential
rate we remap the x-axis then
essentially we're going to be doing
something which corresponds to a
covariant derivative
now the essential part that happens when
we do the
translation of a vector from one tangent
space to another is known as parallel
transport and
the way that we can carry out parallel
transport is basically given by this
relationship for the components of a
vector
if we think about a curve along which
we're doing the parallel transport this
is the law of
the transformation of the components of
that particular Vector X of index K and
it involves all of the changes along the
Curve
with these scaling coefficients for
chart of the connection coefficients
when you do the
parallel transport of the tangent Vector
itself then we get what are known as the
geodesic equations
and in the plane of course the geodesic
equations and including geometry are
just lines but in other cases they are
different on the sphere they are of
course famously known as the great
Circles of the sphere
one thing to keep in mind as we move on
is that if we do alternative types of
connections between the points in the
manifold we will have also different
parallel transports
I'll come back to that
now that we have a notion of how to move
things from one point to the other so
that we can carry out comparisons we
have to address the problem that was
pointed out in the question namely
okay each point is a probability of
distribution so you're clearly not going
to be thinking of doing a euclidean
distance between probability
distributions what does that mean
neither do you want to do anything like
an arbitrary euclidean distance between
the parameters yes it might be expedient
but it has no real meaning what we would
like to do is we would like to think
about how the
property of interest to us changes we're
looking at probability distributions
within an information theoretic
background we're interested in the
information so we're going to be
interested in how we change the
information content as we change the
value of a parameter this is what is
shown here as the change with some
parameter of the PDF of the information
content
now if you try to do that of course you
come across the problem that taking the
expectation of that is zero so that
doesn't work however as introduced by
Fisher the early 20th century we can
introduce a metric based on the idea of
measuring the variance of the change in
the information
so we're going to be taking the
expectation of the second derivative
with respect to the parameters and
essentially what we're going to get here
is that we're going to be measuring the
curvature of the information and that's
going to be our
essential
quantity that we introduce to replace
what would have been the euclidean
distance
with that definition we can define a
metric it's the official information
metric right here
it's going to be the expectation of the
change in the information when we move
along the ith parameter component
times the change in the information when
we move along the jth information
component
and we are now in a position to have a
meaningful
concept of what we would understand by
distance on a statistical manifold it
now corresponds to the change in
information as we move from point to
point on the manifold
here's a simple example
if I just think about the univariate
gaussian just a single mean in a single
variance
we come across a number of features that
we will be working with in more
complicated applications in a very
simple situation namely first off
the universe gaussian depends on two
parameters so it lives in what it looks
like the plane
but the connectivity induced by the
dependence of the probability
distribution upon the parameters is not
that the corresponds to euclidean
Geometry we do not have D mu squared
with a one coefficient and the sigma
squared with a one coefficient both of
them have a coefficient that varies as
the square
inverse square of the variance
so
if you work this out the geodesics that
correspond
to the unit variate
gaussian statistical manifold are those
that we encounter in what is known as
the upward Point Korea half plane they
are ellipses or arcs of ellipse and
lines so whereas in the plane I would
move along a straight line in order to
come to the shorter systems between two
points in
the bunker half plane I have to move
along ellipses or straight lines
on the
horizontal axis over here we have the
mean on the vertical axis we have the
variance or the standard deviation
now this makes problems of
extending our concept of
model reduction from these squares a bit
more difficult
notice that when we were doing this in
linear spaces we knew that we could just
take the orthogonal projection we need
the direction that we would have to go
on is orthogonal to the Subspace
in our case again we have to end up at a
best approximation which is going to be
orthogonal to the Subspace but we're
going to have to do transport on the
Curve
and this transport of the curve now
transforms the problem to a boundary
value problem which is much more
difficult to do especially as the
dimensionality of your statistical
manifold increases essentially you can
have to think about this as having to go
from a point P try a curve figure out
what the angle is here if it's not 90
degrees modify your starting Direction
and so on much as in the shooting
approach to solve a boundary value
Problem by solving an equivalent initial
value problem
we have a question
yeah yeah so how does the geodesic this
distance
induced by the Fisher say this thing
metric uh compare facial information
compared to the something like coolback
labeler distance between two
distributions there must be a connection
right
uh well I'm going to be going to that
when we generalize
they're not
that connected because the official
information metric is a true distance
and as you of course well know the
kobach libraries are semi-distance right
it's a Divergence it doesn't satisfy the
axioms
and the idea now is
which one
is going to be
more appropriate to answering a
particular question if we have as well
showing a simple example in just a bit
a pretty good idea of our phenomenon
then we want to do a minimal
modification of our model
we can think of that as saying well I
would like to do the minimal
modification of the PDF consistent with
some constraints I'll be using the
Fisher information metric
if on the other hand I want to do a
model reduction we'll see that the
Callback library or some other
equivalent divergences play a important
role because they will allow us to do a
computationally efficient generalization
of the Pythagorean theorem so they're
not the same
and if you use the Fisher information
metric for your model reduction you're
gonna always come across this problem of
having to solve a boundary value problem
very expensive computationally
otherwise if you adopt something which
relaxes
the axioms the properties we impose on
our measure of discrepancy do a
semi-distance instead of a distance such
as the cool back Library versions we're
going to be able to do something which
is inefficient Pythagorean theorem
okay and that Pythagorean theorem is
presumably connected to bregman
divergences right
yes it's uh it's something which is
formulated in
what we'll see is the language of dual
connections uh and they can be seen as
particular cases of a pregnant
Divergence yes okay thank you with
different different with different
generating functions of
yeah of course yeah got it thanks
so simple example to kind of um
follow up on what we did yeah suppose
that I do an experiment and I measure
stuff and I get uh statistical estimates
through some statistics of the mean and
the variance
but I know by physical constraints that
the mean has to have some value this is
very usual in most situations I can do a
big molecular Dynamics I have some
stochastic
um variants in that from a thermal
Reservoir but I know that I want to
impose that the first three moments of
my distribution have to correspond to
mass momentum and energy
well
if I have such a constraint this is very
easily shown here suppose that I have
my known mean B minus one for argument's
sake and when I did my measurements I
got this particular value over here how
do I transfer my estimate of the
probability distribution from my
statistical estimates to my constraint
I definitely should not just say oh I go
ahead and
change one of the parameters to the
constraint what I should do is to do the
geodesic transport which in this
particular case would correspond to
moving along a particular ellipse to
move from one value of the beam to
another value of the mean appropriately
changing the
variance such that we do the minimal
change in the Fischer information metric
this is the kind of thing that we'll be
looking at
consistently as we move to more
complicated applications
another way that we can use this in very
simple guys I'll just zoom through this
application is that if we have an active
particle moving through medium and it
eats away at the medium thing bacterium
in a medium and which is feeding uh you
have this kind of flight forage behavior
in which it
executes a local Brownian walk with
gaussian random steps when the feeding
is good and then when it gets poor it
takes a big step as shown by these jumps
over here this is something that we
typically describe through a levy
distribution
and if you run a bunch of stochastic
simulations of these you get very very
many trajectories and you can ask
yourself well okay what does the overall
time dependence of the variance look
like how do I Collapse all of those
things we can do the same thing to come
up with this particular curve here which
is actually a verification of what we
know from experiments of this type and
in this case if you would have just done
things like simple averaging of
disgusting of the stochastic the
distributions of Sigma at various
realizations of the process you would
not have gotten the curve that
corresponds to what we see in
experiments
coming back now to the journal
presentation
let's think about the analytical
framework for some of the more common
families that we encounter this is
what amari's work was on basically to
recognize that the most important
statistical distributions that we
encounter in practice namely those that
have to do with the exponential family
and the Mitchell family are things that
you can
describe analytically
and
here's the
linchpin of this entire Theory namely
you can describe them in a
computationally efficient way through
connecting points in two different ways
you can Define two connections which are
dual of one another
two ways of connecting points mainly
vectors between tangent spaces
and then
as was foreshadowed by our discussion
previously if you relax your definition
of what you mean by distance to a
semi-distance
you can then formulate the equivalent of
a
Pythagorean theorem namely if I move
from one probability distribution to
another R it can be as stated as the
Divergence from
that probability distribution to an
intermediate one and then the
intermediate one to the second
furthermore and this is the interesting
aspect that was pointed out by Mari
you can
in the Dual connections render all of
the important statistical families be
flat in one of the coordinates
so all of a sudden you can if you do one
of the coordinate systems
have the property that you don't have to
go along a curve you can go along a
straight line to be orthogonal to the
surface
the penalty that you pay is that by
Contra distinction to least squares you
have to always do changes of coordinates
and those changes of coordinates are
known they're been published by Omarion
so on but it allows you now to
efficiently
think about the generalization of least
squares to curve the linear families of
statistical manifolds
let's now move on from that overall
analytical framework to something which
is of interest to us namely how do you
do computation with all of this
well computationally
we're really Limited in what we have
that is efficient the Workhorse is of
course the SVD and we know what it
corresponds to it's going to give us
something that is a local gaussian
approximation
of the physical manifold so the picture
that I would like to present to you is
the following
I have a system
if I gather data about the system over
some sub interval of the evolution time
I can definitely figure out
an SVD of that data which I can think of
as a local gaussian approximation to
some underlying statistical manifold
which I do not yet know
that underline statistical manifold is
assumed for mesoscale physics to
actually be something which does not
correspond to a gaussian so the
situation you find yourself in is kind
of something suggested by this picture
you have a bunch of
shapes of known form
in our case there would be hyper
ellipsoids and the envelope of that is
the manifold that you want to work on
the difficulty that you have now is that
you do this at the sweet times you don't
know the underlying dimension of the
manifold
and you have to somehow figure all of
this out
I'll go through
an overview of how this is being done
it's um an overview due to time
constraints can't possibly go through
all these details but I'm glad to talk
with anybody that's interested
essentially you have a point cloud
that correspond to various PDFs each of
them a local
gaussian approximation and then we use
the idea of nested complexes and
persistent homology to figure out the
intrinsic dimension of the underlying
manifold
this is something which is being used in
a bunch of applications
and I'll probably not go more than hand
wave about it essentially there's a
rational way in which as we increase the
connectivity between the points and the
complexes that we can come up with an
idea of what the most probable dimension
of the underlying manifold is
foreign
this is something that is typically
shown as these persistence diagrams and
barcode diagrams and once we have that
working on that manifold we say okay
we're we want to build a local
parameterization a local parametrization
is something that we can do in a
piecewise
uh linear fashion by just doing
simplicia in high dimensions and at any
given node we have a discrete evaluation
of the curvature just by all of the
faces of the simplicia that have that
node as a common vertex
so we can include all of the information
that we get from svds acquired during
the simulation into a representation of
an underlying manifold
let me present a couple of applications
of these ideas
again in the interest of just showing
the flavor of where this might lead to
one is a rather straightforward
application to
something probably familiar to most
people a way to do lattice boltzmann or
lattice methods in general and the other
one is going to be a much more involved
application that has to do with
biomechanics
Madison
briefly go over it that's the boltzmann
equation
our expansion
we get at various orders so alert heavy
stocks per net and the way that we get
those is by just Computing those moments
to get the various kinds of
approximations
what is the linchpin of the last
boltzmann method you describe the
velocity space and you then carry out
the streaming step in which you move
particles to a lot of sites but then you
have the problem of modeling collision
and collision is the recognition that at
the kinetic level you're not necessarily
at equilibrium now we're in the
framework that we are
interested in of a mesoscale phenomena
that is not equilibrated
so how can you approach this
well
the standard way which is in most Lata
Sportsman simulations is to say Well it
kind of relaxes at some time and this is
the bgk with single relaxation time
which you can then finesse into
something a bit better by introducing
multiple relaxation time for various
moments that correspond to
Mass momentum energy and so on
foreign
both of these though are known to be
highly restrictive in terms of the flows
that they can describe they can't
describe High Mark or high Reynolds flow
and the reason is that you have a very
simple
representation of the relaxation
the way that
you can
alleviate these restrictions
that lead to either the necessity of
very large computational time or very
fine grids
that is suggested but what we've done in
the framework we have goes as follows
well you have data you have data from
your current state of the microscopic
system and then what you would like to
do is instead of going
along
the bgk path
and make a straight line
from your current approximation to where
you want to arrive out of the
equilibrated
you construct a manifold of probability
distributions and generate a geodesic on
that path
the amount of distance that you travel
on the geodesic is something that is
immediately related to the time step and
the viscosity of the fluid that you have
and this then allows you to rapidly
compute with no instability things like
the speed at Reynolds number is up to 10
to the 5 or so we've achieved and Mach
numbers in the low range but low
supersonic range we're up to Mach 2.
another application which now involves
multiple levels
is going to be suggested by biomechanics
this is Joint work that involves a
number of people here at UNC in which we
have brain tissue that is subjected to
trauma and we're interested in how that
trauma
imposed by impacts at the macro scale
reflects into micro tissue
and the idea here is that the micro
damage is done at the level of
individual axons within the brain so
they have to move from a continued model
for a stochastic medium
to a representation of the medium as
being a bunch of fibers connected to one
another and then the fibers themselves
being composed of microtubules that
themselves have a stochastic structure
based upon the
molecular dynamics of Alpha and beta
tubulin
this is
a application which we apply the
framework at various levels
I'll briefly glance over and leave more
time for questions if possible
namely within a hyperelastic framework
that corresponds to the continuing
Behavior
your main question is what is the
constitutive law that relates stress to
deformation
and that is something that you can come
up with
by including
all effects the elastic and the viscous
effects and then doing instantiations of
the measurements
that are doing realizations from
measurements and then applying our
framework to come up with
a constitutive model which is data
driven essentially all of the data that
we get from measurements are as soon as
data points that lie on the manifold and
then we go to the minimal such model in
order to come up with something that now
closely fits the data red line going
through the data points that we have
same approach then applies if you want
to do things like what is the
probability distribution orientation of
fibers within the brain
because these though they have a general
orientation imposed by the brain
structure also have
variability in how that particular
orientation is realized
and finally
if you look at the structure of
the neurons they have this axon over
here
and the axial in the cross section is
just a bunch of microtubules
that you would like to find the
mechanical properties of in order to be
able to figure out when they break
so same principles you have a stochastic
simulation this time is given by
molecular Dynamics anyone that
do a reduction of that
to something which is amenable I've we
have a publication on this done at zero
temperature and we've extended this now
to non-zero temperature by the methods
that we've allowed outlined up to this
point
then
same
principle applies to probability
distribution for fiber orientations
at the end of the day allowing you to do
and I'll close with this
predictions of where you get individual
axons breaking by combining these three
applications of the information
framework
approach to model reduction namely at
the Continuum level in order to find
conservative parameters
at the mesoscale level to determine
fiber networks of neurons and at the
microscopic level to determine
mechanical properties of magnitubules to
the point that if you combine all of
those you do come up with a prediction
of where axons break that are matched
qualitatively at least we're always
happy with qualitative as the first
thing
with what you get from staining
measurements
and with that I'll acknowledge supports
and um hopefully everybody has a glimpse
into the workshop over here and please
ask questions or suggest things that you
would like to talk about in
collaborations or just brainstorming
thank you so much
thank you so much sorry that was a
wonderful talk and uh very informative
um all right let's have a q a session
um and yeah pause
anyone has a question please unmute
yourself and then
ask questions
no questions
any other applications you can you can
you mention other than the the one you
have showed so far today
uh yeah we're doing fracture
um in in the same framework
mostly the medical applications yeah no
fracture is for um applications with um
these are military applications so oh I
see exfoliation fracture
um High kinetic impact
other situations in which you are very
far away from equilibrium when you do
the simulations and you can't trust your
conservative model
very cool
these days the people try to apply the
machine learning to come up with the
unknown constitutive role as well
yeah there's also an interesting uh link
between machine learning and all of this
I didn't go into that but
the weights uh that you have on a deep
neural network you can interpret the
nestochastic processes and it turns out
that
there's a stochastic gradient descent
procedure kind of corresponds to a
information minimization on the
stochastic process parameters yeah right
all right
any questions from audience
if not let's thank our speaker today
sorry and and thank you so much for the
wonderful talk Serene and um as uh sorry
mentioned if
any if you have any idea of the past
potential collaborations please let
sorry knows that's kind of the one of
the main motivation for this seminar
series and the workshop so yeah I I have
a lot more a lot more details but I
prefer just to raise everybody's
interest so yeah yeah you did a good job
okay yeah all right thank you thank you
sorry okay so let me push the
stop button